[Applause]
do you all know anything about this
matt gates gets what how do you
pronounce this [ __ ]
yeah matt what is it matt gates yeah
matt gates
gates yeah okay matt gates is this
republican
congressman congressman from the great
state of florida florida having a rough
little month he's north florida bro we
don't like we don't claim him
yeah no he's north florida he's
pensacola
now we are at all bro
how are you being a coastal elite with
your own state i'm central i'm central
i rep central like that's that's my
that's my area crazy [ __ ] happens in
miami i don't care it's not me
no no no no no no no you can rent
whatever you want bro
whatever decides to tax laws okay
if the north decides that we're going to
save 14 of taxes that's the side i rep
i whoever decides the taxes all right
they pay more or less than the north
matt gates probably don't want you
paying taxes matt don't be paying taxes
bro
yeah yeah you know who doesn't pay taxes
the girls match gates
because somebody just ain't all the good
jobs
maybe you just wanted to be dependent on
his return bro so is it true he was
smoking out 17 years old that's the
allegation
whole research that's that was the first
allegation and then he went on
tucker carlson and like tried to drag
tucker into it
no he was like
where he's on tucker's show and he's
like yeah you know like you know i'm not
that kind of guy right tucker like your
wife and you have been on dates with me
yeah and my girlfriend yes and talker's
like i don't know if that's happened
like that
like he like after the foul that's fine
after the interview tucker was like uh
that was one of the weirdest interviews
i've ever been a part of like he wanted
nothing to do with the books
yeah come on [ __ ] try to throw
me hey
[ __ ] you i'm not gonna touch the girl
jujitsu
that is foul okay so he's accused of
flying out he was flying out at 17.
that's why they're saying they fly alone
yeah is that how they caught her did she
have to be
she had to have a chaperone yeah they
said where's your mom
yeah the pilot gave her like little
wings they're like oh go have fun
she took a picture in the cockpit what
epstein airline was just flying lolita
lolita express
to pensacola okay so he got he was
really having sex with his 17th that's
the allegation yeah
that he flew her around and she was 17
years old at the time but then there's
also allegations now of
him i remember [ __ ] 17 year old joe
yeah that's an important disclaimer to
put on you can't just ask the question
but like
you remember it when you were 17. you
luckily yeah do you remember when you
were 17.
mark does not either yo no now
[ __ ] that right i was 16 be like yo are
you legal yeah
your [ __ ] money are you legal [ __ ]
like are you
damn bro i'm just saying like why would
you ask a 17 year old
like [ __ ] just gets better as you get
older yeah it does you know what i'm
saying
like you're he's 39 years old this guy
matt getz
something like that and you're going
after 17 year olds yeah that's a little
while it just
it doesn't make any sense the only sense
it could make
is if you're a [ __ ] creep pedophile
he's 38.
wasn't he a big q anon guy i think so
he's just a wild kid like if you go to
his controversies page on wikipedia
oh and this is the other thing
apparently he voted against a uh
a sex trafficking bill that was proposed
in the united states so some type of
like anti-sexual
that one was the one where he was the
only person yeah everyone was like yeah
of course yeah sex driving is bad it's
something to this effect is
oversimplified and he was like
well you know it's nuanced and like
voted no or some [ __ ]
no respect it's it's time it's
consistency bro yeah
that's consistent hey that's a good
point bro
that's all i'm saying you're right i
almost tapped my nose and did that to
you
what is that what is that i got to be
doing that [ __ ] like we know what it is
i don't know what it is
yeah that means i'm with you i'm with
you i'm with you oh in what
engaged that respect is consistency so
i'm saying you're right i'm with you
can we at least respect the consistency
the dude is out here traffic and puss
which is wrong it would be inconsistent
of me to [ __ ] on michael rappaport and
then not give this guy some credit
that's it for being up being consistent
[ __ ] went into that vote like
these haters
haters man every time i come to work the
haters is after me
[ __ ] bro i'm just i was 17 year olds
with the ladies
the floaties it's not the heavies it's
the ladies
can i live with the light lights no that
may be great
right it gets more wild though because
apparently he's saying that he's being
extorted and that there was allegedly
like messages sent to his father
don gates oh some prominent guys saying
demanding money in exchange
to make the allegations go away no way
what was god
saying that's what was saying what don
had to say he was like
this is crazy he just had his country
girl like hey
ain't it crazy like when your son be
[ __ ] these underage brothers like
y'all know how it is right
like you just got your son [ __ ]
underage girls they try to bring you
into it and extort some money out here
yeah come on sweetheart hop off my lap
hop on my lap get into the ball pit
again
you know that's generational you know
his dad don't got no problem with that
[ __ ] no
come on and now there's allegedly photos
of him at a
prostitute orgy or some [ __ ] whoa whoa
whoa what that's not going on
hold on now that's not yeah what's the
age of these [ __ ]
can i can we be honest who leaked this
can we be honest who leaked this
yep the [ __ ] goat the scientist
desantis had some heat on his seat them
heat warmers were on three bars
right the heat warmers was on three bars
right there like yo desantis why'd you
under report all the dead people and he
was like
haters haters after me bro
what's the deal like i'm just trying to
keep my [ __ ] state open
we just try to open her up and these
haters is worried about dead old people
and they're dying these haters they're
dying [ __ ] up my numbers
[ __ ] them up so do you think they
killed his story with a crazier story
matt getz gates bro
he's always got to get it right yes he's
not learning they might think we're
talking about someone else
the way he spells it though infuriates
me bro
do you know how he spells this g-a-e-t-z
g-a-e-t-z
gat gayets gates i guess
there's always gates gates
open her up up
yeah yo is it wrong that i forgive
desantis
but not gates i don't i don't forgive
gates what do you forgive the sanders
for whatever he did
anything anything that we know about so
far okay
okay yeah then he lied about the dead
people okay yeah you went very specific
yeah well he didn't do nothing with them
17 year olds right why you forgive him
why did i forgive him yeah because he's
lit going to restaurants yeah
yeah that's a good point i care more
about restaurants than old people i
don't know
actually that's up there
unfortunately that's a fact someone's
like yo you care more about going out
to mr child or these old people than mr
chow
[Laughter]
when you really think about it mr
charles and we need to talk about this
whole thing this whole pandemics poke
the bears
what i'm not poking a bear dog you think
i'm poking the bear
the panda the winner
okay so um where do we stand with with
gates and uh desantis listen it's
uncomfortable to stand with gates right
now so let's see what happens there i'm
not with you at the moment
are you pro gates
what do you do to me you say he's not
with me yeah well i'm not with gabriel
you standing with gates son he just puts
you in a state of mind
gates that's where he's hanging out food
is trash yeah food is trash he don't
care about the food dog
i'll tell you this i'll tell you you
know
[Laughter]
because we'd cut it out anyway but if
that 17 year old [ __ ] had a hook up at
car bone i definitely would be okay with
that gates going out
get her a kid's menu hey got some
jiggity dendes out here bro
i got some jiggity dendes and some
french fries for these little [ __ ]
and matt gates me dating open her up
oh my god jesus hey jesus
jesus this guy's great really dude on
easter you're gonna do this does he he's
dead
hey you know what's rising maggie's dick
we need to [ __ ] relax okay tell me
why
dove brought two peppers to the house
today
tell me
that's just irresponsible dude there's
sinkholes there's sinkholes in florida
cave in the whole house brought the 600
pound lives
he really did it was a tlc show
i thought we were filming something for
tlc doug yeah i walked right out of my
room
i did bro i did i couldn't say anything
i didn't know how to speak yeah i
literally out
i didn't know how to speak i went up to
him can i get you guys some water some
harvey
what did you guys need i literally
didn't know what to say
i didn't have to speak to them they
asked me they're like where's the
bathroom i go you can just use that
heavy rain
seriously the girl came out she's like
listen there's no soap in the bathroom
then she said there was no soap left in
the bathroom i was like did you check in
the shower underneath the habit did you
see that there
may be something there did you see it
did you see it hey
there might be some over there okay
okay come on now i couldn't believe
these poor girls
i couldn't believe them bro why would
they even be talking like that we gotta
take a break
no why would they we they you know i had
to take a break their [ __ ] bathing
suits
had to take a break oh my god it was
unbelievable bro
it was unbelievable unbelievable bro
[Music]
honestly the best thing was the tits
that's the best thing it was the heavies
was the best thing
and two [ __ ] saxa goldfish
andrew's girl walks them out golden
doodle walking behind
and his girl goes your guests are here
dove yeah
yes yes that's what she said god bless
her sweet fiance of mine
literally she texted me she's like
andrew
is that what the doorbell said
for real that's all that was happening
bro
what ow take a deep breath
bro take a deep breath you gotta
watch those girls take a deep breath
it's tremendous
you know those those boobs were real big
guys
those boobs were real big milkers bro yo
they really
you know mark said the other day there
was this girl with huge tits at the
[ __ ] show yeah they were massive
mark goes mark goes you should tattoo
missing kids on those
[Applause]